hola yo soy frank allan y soy la
directora técnica de la simulación
física de la ropa en los estudios pixar
y eso significa que tomo lo que sé de
arte y diseño para hacer vestuarios y lo
que conozco de matemáticas y física para
hacer que se muevan y el día de hoy
vamos a hablar acerca de multitudes como
la enorme multitud que tengo detrás de
mí excepto porque la que tengo detrás de
mí es una multitud real y las que
tenemos que hacer para nuestros vídeos
son virtuales eso quiere decir que
existen en la computadora en el vídeo
pasado vimos cómo se pueden construir un
montón de robots con solo unas piezas a
través del uso de la combinatoria el 10
que sigue me y vamos a aprender mucho
más acerca de qué es la combinatoria y
cómo la usamos aquí en pixar
para entender cómo se pueden hacer
muchos robots a partir de cierto montón
de partes vamos a empezar con un ejemplo
donde un robot tiene una cabeza y un
cuerpo y además puedo escoger entre dos
tipos diferentes de cabezas
y entre tres cuerpos así es que puedo
tomar esta cabeza con este cuerpo o la
misma cabeza pero ahora con este cuerpo
y ahí ya tenemos dos tipos diferentes de
robots y claramente puedo hacer
muchísimos más ahora una muy buena forma
de llevar la cuenta es con una tabla en
la que voy a poner las cabezas a lo
largo de las columnas y los cuerpos a lo
largo de las filas estas celdas
significan con esta cabeza con este
cuerpo y hay seis celdas en esta tabla
por lo que tiene que haber seis robots
distintos aunque únicamente tenemos
cinco partes distintas este es un buen
ejemplo de cómo encontrar una buena
forma de pensar en un problema hace que
sea más fácil de resolver
y cuántos robots puedes hacer si tienes
distintos números de cabezas y de
cuerpos puedes explorar esa pregunta en
el próximo ejercicio